I say zoo I'm not here to discuss this
with my mind when I say jump you jump
I'm not here to have a discussion with
you your mind has the ultimate tactical
advantage over you my mind can be my
worst enemy wanna be happy
build a life not just the business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how you can condition
your mind for success okay let's kick it
off with hack number one train your mind
with Tony Robbins the most common
question I've been asked by the media my
entire life that always makes me wear
outfits don't you have bad days don't
have days when you're like frosty and
anxiety pissed off and you watch TV and
you eat Cheetos and watch pornography
and I said why do some of those things
and of course I do but what I it's like
an athlete I built muscle over the years
so that it's not that I don't have
feelings that I get hurt at the saddle
throat I feel all those things but
they're not the dominant force in my
life it's a muscle
the mind is a muscle emotion is a muscle
I mean I think the most powerful muscles
are the invisible force muscles it's
your spiritual emotional muscles like
courage on youth doesn't grow shrinks so
I put my ass on the line regularly so
that it grows and when it keeps girl and
then pretty soon those stuff that used
to make me crazy it doesn't touch me
it's not that I'm so great just I'm well
trained I have trained this mind I get
up every morning my life you talk about
rebounder more crazy ideas everywhere in
your life if I'm near if I'm near any of
my homes in some places I have I have
cryotherapy but my homes I have these
coal plungers and they're 56 degrees and
the first thing I do is jump in that
cold punch there's not a morning where I
want to jump in that I can't remember
one good job in that thing but I don't
negotiate with myself I do it for two
reasons one there's a physical health
component moves your lymph system and
the blood rushes through your whole body
but the main reason I do it even more
than that is when I go up there I don't
you know people negotiate laughs I'm
able to tomorrow I'm gonna do this or
I'll let me wait two more minutes time
ready
there's no that with me for decades I go
I say do I'm not here to discuss this
with my mind
there's mind and then there's soul and
spirit and soul spirit my soul knows it
when I say jump you jump I'm not here to
have a discussion with you pack number 2
seas
control with david Goggins your mind has
the ultimate tactical advantage over you
it knows what scars you it it knows your
fears and those your insecurities and it
protects you was right I talked about
the 40% rule in my book the 40% rules
all about the brain has the tactical
advantage over you it knows and it keeps
you away from all that that's why it
says don't jump out of airplane
don't go on the ocean with their sharks
it's a protective mechanism don't go
back to the place where your dad beat
the [ __ ] out of you in your mind don't
go back the brain protects you it
protects you so much it doesn't allow
growth so the brain is an amazing thing
but the brain controls you you must
control it you must take power over your
own mind or your mind will guide you
into all the soft speights
soft places that your brain wants to
live in Jupiter has enough information
it doesn't want to go through that
process of of mind hardening doesn't
want to do that I can't remember what
time I got to be here what time I gotta
be there this is why we're today I'm
peaceful it wants to stay very peaceful
away from scarring also if you want to
have more motivation check out my 254
series they're free the links join on
the description below you've got to
separate the vehicle from the outcome
what is it that's gonna truly fulfill
you what is it that's gonna give you
that extraordinary life everything I
didn't want to do is what got me to
where I'm at today you might want to get
honest with yourself
I can stead of doing this be a
millionaire or do this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
Hawk number three start playing big with
EDM islet I feel like most people in
their lives are being allowed to live
small you're allowed to live a small
life everyone around you would like you
to live small just do this you're good
at that man take it easy chill wins
enough enough like come on brother
you know we're weak all these messes you
get is basically saying hey man live
yeah life's not a big deal live small
enjoy it chill smoke a little weed do
whatever you want to walk great like
it's just this get by thing in life
there's got to be something to go no no
you're supposed to do something great
with your life you were put here for a
purpose your way the way you were born
the way you were raised your background
your experiences your giftedness all
prepared you in your way for right now
and you're supposed to do something
great with your life you weren't born
here to be average and ordinary and
there's all this messaging that your
average and ordinary and your average
annoy because you belong there and it's
probably someone else's fault your
average an ordinary to it I'm like no
it's your life
you're in control it's no one else's
fault and you're supposed to do
something magnificent that's the
consciousness aspect the last thousand
years on earth doing something great has
been reserved to this one little group
of people one percent of the population
they're supposed to do something great
they're supposed to live their dreams
we're supposed to watch them cheer for
them wear their Jersey watch their award
show comment on their posts clean their
houses right feed them in their
restaurants no the fact of the matter is
you can do those things you can change
your life and I'm sick and tired of this
hero worship you live small cheer for
everybody else who lives big no if
you're a school teacher be the best damn
school teacher change the world buy
those little lives you're affected if
you're on social media change the role
play big you will never do it wrong if
your decisions to do the bigger thing
than the smaller thing that's what I
would tell you stop playing small stop
thinking small and don't let anybody
tell you you should be small and half
number four the last one before very
special bonus clip is reset your mindset
with Mel Robbins my mind can be my worst
enemy I was laying in bed last night
and I had fallen asleep and I kept
waking up and you know what I was
thinking about I was waking up because I
could hear people in the hallway kind of
coming in from a late night up hurting
and you know what the first thing that
my mind defaulted to there being a fire
in the hotel and I started having these
visions of my daughter and I going down
the stairwell and getting trapped and
then I had visions of us being on the
balcony
this room and fire kind of engulfing and
what are we doing or retiring a rope
wish I mean it's just insanity absolute
insanity and I I used the techniques
that I teach you I went five four three
two one I am not thinking about this and
the thought disappeared because I
constantly reset my mindset and you know
one of the reasons why I'm telling you
this is if you are tired of feeling
negative if you feel often that your own
thoughts are the things that trip you up
in life that you wish that your mind
were more positive I'm telling you that
I'm the same way just because I teach
this stuff just because I study this
just because I do what I do for a living
doesn't make me immune to what it means
to be human and what it means to be
human is that your brain and your body
want you to survive your brain and your
body
remember situations that scare the
daylights out of you your brain and your
body try to talk you out of anything
that makes you feel risky and your brain
given that it has been trained by
situations in the past and given that
you allow it to worry all the time you
have a habit of doing it if you're not
careful and you're not deliberate your
brain will default to scary crap like
mine was last night that doesn't mean
you're broken it means that your brain
is thinking something that's broken and
it's time for you to reset your mindset
and pull it back now I have a special
bonus clip from Marisa Pierre on how to
hack your brain that I think you can
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what's the mindset reset that you need
to make number two how can you start
playing bigger and number three where do
you need to see
control and if you made it this far in
the video I want to celebrate you give
me a hashtag believe down the comments
people think the brain is really
complicated it's not it's actually quite
simple you need to know three things
about your brain to always get what you
want and the first thing is your brain
does exactly what it thinks you want it
to do because it listens to everything
you say so when you say things like oh
god you know I got dumped it's so
painful I never want to go through that
again all your mind can pick up is you
don't want to be in a relationship again
when people have a miscarriage ago I
could never never go through that again
I'd rather die than go through that
again your mind is speaking up oh right
well that's that's a statement that's
actually a command to me to make sure
you never go through miscarriage again
and that that's how you get unexplained
infertility which is something else I've
been working on a lot recently because
the mind listen story says we will go I
went on this fly if it was gonna die and
do it look I'm never getting my play if
this plane lands I will never ever get
on a plane again and of course it lands
they go is just turbulence but next time
they go to the airport of a massive
panic attack because your minds like
hang on a minute you said I never want
to fly again and so if you haven't got
what you want it's because you're giving
your mind very confusing messages your
minds number one job is to listen to
what you say to interact on it the
second job is to move you towards
pleasure and away from pain and it will
always always always do more to avoid
pain so let's imagine you've gone for an
interview you've done it this public
speech thing like me and you've stood up
you've got oh my god I'm never doing
this again and you'd have a terrible
presentation and one of my clients work
for Sony was saying that she had to
stand up just say to Sony this is a new
band from Camden and she stood up and
went this is a new band from and they're
called should I I couldn't do it is a
simplest thing and my boss had to take
over and I was explaining to her that
when you do that and go
I don't want to do it I don't want to do
this again your mind is now going to
make sure you don't do it again so the
next time you go to speak it will give
you a panic attack or make you ill and
if you say to yourself oh my god I'd
love a week off in bed or I'm dreading
next wait and say your mind just so in
tune with you a week off in bed you wake
up with a flu anyone's like they go how
cool am i there's your weak impaired you
do want to go to that speech I've woken
you up with diarrhea so now you can't go
that's what the mind does when I was
giving my first ever presentation about
my first ever book I woke up with the
most excruciating my own over hangover I
thought wow I must have been saying to
myself Sam I don't want to do this
because I've got this migraine and I
actually went and did it and I didn't
have the migraine until I stepped back
off the stage again and I realized that
I was communicating very badly with
myself so you must never say nervous say
excited because your mind listen so
those three things are your mind does
what it really thinks you want to do if
you're very very specific and so I want
this and this I want to be a great
speaker I want to deliver things I want
to be fantastic at sales I want to be
able to look Google I and sell them
things and come across as really
authentic your mind will understand and
if you make those pictures really good
and pleasant you'll move towards them
if you want to know some monk secrets
that will change your life check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
I think the number one thing to do is to
build the mini dream first if you try to
control the variety of situations